en norvège au moment de noël
on raconte aux enfants une histoire
merveilleuse il était une fois dans un
royaume lointain un roi frappé par une
cruelle malédiction voilà dix ans que ma
fille a disparu à c'est le dixième noël
cire elle sera perdue à jamais telle est
la prophétie à moins de ramener au
château l'étoile du nord
pour redonner espoir à tous les cieux
une jeune orpheline
cessons de rêver d'autres pages
t'attendent va changer ce questionnaire
je demande audience au roi culture sir
je vous ramènerai l'étoile du nord
beaucoup ont échoué avant toi mais tu as
le coeur pur
tu es mon dernier espoir
embarquez pour un grand voyage
je m'appelle moussy six mois
dans un monde enchanté
qu'ils aient dû parsemer 2000 danger
le roi devra bientôt renoncer au trône
elle ne doit pas trouvée l'étoile opare
vidal ce noël
laissez vous envoûter par le plus
ferrique des comptes
le secret d'une étoile du nord le 11
décembre au cinéma